Prime Deli it's a battle who will the
jury believe the retired optometrist who
says his life was changed by an accident
on a Utah ski slope did you think it was
cool
to collide with a celebrity absolutely
not that is not who I am no no or will
it be celebrity actress and entrepreneur
Gwyneth Paltrow Mr Sanderson
categorically hit me on that ski slope
and that is the truth will the army of
attorneys be able to prove what happened
on the hill or is this just a classic
case of he said she said our own legal
analysts weigh in on the contradictory
testimony Straight Ahead lawn crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber we're bringing you
some of the biggest moments from the
Utah Civil Trial involving a-lister
Gwyneth Paltrow as she faces accusations
that she slammed into a man on a ski
slope several years ago Terry Sanderson
a retired Eye Doctor Who's now in his
70s testified Monday about how a
collision with Gwyneth Paltrow in 2016
impacted his life now days before on
Friday sanderson's attorney called
Gwyneth Paltrow herself to the stand to
get her account of what happened
Sanderson Paltrow were going down the
same ski run at Deer Valley Resort when
one hit the other sending both of them
to the ground What's Up For Debate right
now is who ran into whom Sanderson
claims that Paltrow slammed into him
from behind leaving him with several
broken ribs and an apparent brain injury
meantime Paltrow says she felt someone
hit her in the back Sanderson is looking
for at least three hundred thousand
dollars in compensation his lawyers
allege that the case is actually worth
millions Paltrow countersued for just
one dollar plus a attorney's fees one of
sanderson's lawyers went over testimony
that Paltrow had given in previous
depositions confirming some key details
you're going down relatively slowly when
all of a sudden you heard a strange
rustling noise behind you yes okay and
you felt like a rush of air in a strange
way yes okay and two skis slid in
between my skis that's correct and all
of a sudden there was a body from the
whole front of a body pressing into my
back that's right okay
like
like we'll talk about this in a minute
and there was a man behind me pressing
into me how did you know it was a man
because he was making some strange
noises that sounded male
and he was large so I assumed it was a
male okay he was large I felt all my
back okay pressing okay
um all right there was a man pressing
behind me pressing into me I was
extremely upset
well I was confused at first and I
didn't know exactly what was happening
it's a very strange thing to happen on
the ski slope
um I agree
and I froze and it I would say I was got
very upset a couple seconds later okay
and you're not saying to the jury that
this was in any way shape or form a
sexual assault I am not saying that I'm
just saying what went through my mind
for a split second when it was happening
all right so
ground
I I don't remember if I started yelling
at him while I was on the ground I
remember pushing away because I was very
upset and it was still very strange to
me what had happened
um and I pushed down the hill and I
turned around and I said and I yelled at
him okay
day went down
I don't think so okay
so feathers heard a scream you wouldn't
that wasn't you no I froze when he slid
between my skis I absolutely froze and I
don't remember yelling or Screaming
until I was very angry at what had
happened okay and so you guys are on the
ground
um and then you said to him I think you
don't know if you were up or if you were
still on the ground but he was still on
the ground right yes when you said what
are you doing yes okay like why did you
do that yes and he said I think you
skied into me yes and that's when you
were Furious and said you skied directly
into my effing back
at the top of your lungs yes I did okay
I apologize for my bad language
joined right now by my co-host former
trial Attorney Terry Austin defense
attorney Brian buckmeyer Brian I'll
start with you so he said she said so a
major question is did you find Paltrow
credible Jesse I think at the end of the
day I did but I'm not sure it's based on
her testimony but more so on the lack of
the of the attorney getting those
hard-hitting facts out of her typically
when you are the plaintiff and you have
the opposing party on the stand you're
going to get some hard-hitting questions
you're going to challenge their
credibility they're going to challenge
the recollection of what happened but
this seemed like two friends going over
what happened uh also when I saw the
attorney being a woman questioning
Gwyneth Paltrow a lot of us as attorneys
optically think okay if it's a a smaller
female person you're going to
cross-examine or question you get
another woman because optically it looks
bad when a man is yelling at her I
didn't see that I thought she had the
ability to but she didn't so she's
credible because of maybe lack of
questioning talking about raising her
voice so Paltrow admits to getting angry
Terry you think that the jury's going to
hold that against her you know I think
her explanation was really really good
and I think the jury won't hold it
against her it makes sense she's on a
ski slope she feels someone
getting behind her she's probably
thinking it might have been an assault
or a sexual assault now she claims
obviously that was not what was
happening but At first she thought that
was what happened and so because of that
she's yelling at him and she cursed and
she apologized very well understand I
think that was very incredible she felt
as though look I probably shouldn't have
cursed but because of the shock of it
all that's why I reacted the way I
didn't so I think the jury will
understand that she didn't stop to help
at that point because she's still in
shock well more to talk about when it
comes to this case still ahead on Long
crime daily highlights from the Gwyneth
Paltrow skiing lawsuit continue a lot
more to cover
were you knocked out I was not knocked
out no
do you have memory loss of the event I
do not I mean it was a long time ago but
sure and we're taking you back to a Utah
courtroom where both the plaintiff and
defendant in this case had a chance to
testify
[Music]
and welcome back everybody so our
coverage of the Civil Trial involving
actress Gwyneth Paltrow rose on now
Paltrow took the stand on Friday she's
the defendant in a lawsuit filed by
Terry Sanderson accusing her of slamming
into him on a Utah ski slope causing
serious impermanent injuries now Paltrow
as we mentioned filed a counter suit
saying that Sanderson has it all
backwards and that actually he hit her
after some back and forth about the
impact the accident had on Paltrow's day
her own attorney brought up some
misconceptions that people might have
take a listen
I do okay and he has deterred you from
enjoying the rest of what was a very
expensive vacation
well I lost
half a day of skiing wow
yes okay and I think that's
that's what your Council has argued as
well that you lost you had a full day
pass but you can only ski a half a day
yes I went back down after lunch okay
right and that's when you had lunch and
you got a massage yeah
um didn't get your knee checked out
didn't have any kind of medical
attention
no it didn't feel acute in any way it
felt just like I had overstretched my
knee and I had sustained a blow but it
didn't feel like it needed medical
attention okay there's an implication
that at the time of this Collision you
were distracted were you distracted no
were you paying attention to where you
were skiing I was was there anyone in
front of you there was not
do you feel some empathy for Mr
Sanderson and this
declining brain you know I really do I
feel very sorry for him it seems like
he's had a very difficult life
but I did not cause the accident so I
cannot be at fault for anything that
subsequently happened to him
so Brian Paltrow was talked about and
she asked about distractions even
Sanderson brought up that he saw two
signs that he's as he skied how
important is it whether or not either
one of them were distracted or Reckless
as they skied Jesse this whole case is
about being distracted or being Reckless
because when it comes to sports there is
an assumption of risk everyone knows
this I mean I played college soccer I
think I've got what three fractures a
break and bruised ribs I didn't I wasn't
able to sue any of the people who did
that to me because a part of playing the
sport means you get injured however if
you're skiing and you're distracted or
you're doing something that goes beyond
what is the normal course of that sport
then you can be considered liable to the
damage or the harm that you do to other
people so it cannot just be that they
were skiing and doing their regular
um skiing so to speak there has to be
something more so I thought it was weird
for Sanderson to bring up the signs
because that shows that he might have
been distracted but I think Paltrow has
to explain that there was no distraction
she was doing exactly what she's
supposed to be doing and that was skiing
well Terry Paltrow's team's arguing that
sanderson's overall health wasn't very
good before the accident and continued
to decline because of normal aging you
think that's a good argument to go with
oh I think it's a great argument I
believe that all of these medical issues
before could have contributed to the
accident frankly the fact that he had a
bad knee he had poor vision he had heart
palpitations he was on medication and
all of that could have made him run into
Gwyneth Paltrow and the other issue is
he got angry even before the accident so
some of his personality changes honestly
weren't changes at all and the other
issue that I think Paltrow's team is
trying to assert here is look you've got
some declining brain function but you're
an older person and that's what happens
I have empathy for you but I did not
cause it I think that's a very important
point and a great argument yeah because
it's not enough that the Collision would
have caused the injuries it's that only
if he was hit could this have happened
and that's the key there so you know
that's the leap that the jury ultimately
has to take now coming up on Long crime
daily we hear from the plaintiff in the
case who brought the lawsuit against
Gwyneth Paltrow what Terry Sanderson had
to say when he got on the stand Monday
seven years after the incident that
trans formed his life
[Music]
and welcome back everybody so we're
continuing to cover Gwyneth Paltrow and
Terry sanderson's skiing Collision
lawsuit and on Monday the plaintiff
testified sanderson's testimony comes
after his daughters and Paltrow took the
stand his children described his
apparent shift in personality and
lifestyle after the Collision going from
a happy-go-lucky guy to a slower more
isolated version of himself now Paltrow
insisted on the stand that Sanderson was
responsible for the incident and even
thought someone was quote doing
something perverted based on how both
parties landed on the slope on the
stands Sanderson rebutted Paltrow's
claims while also being challenged by
her defense team
I just remember everything was great and
then I heard something I've never heard
of the ski resort and that was a blood
curdling stream
just I can't do it it was
and then
and
it was like
somebody was out of control and gonna
hit a tree and was gonna die and that's
what I had until I was hit that's what
was going on in your mind
over overruled
that's what's going on in your mind when
you hear that scream
that's instances oh my gosh somebody's
out of control Carleen we heard her
tested by last week she's a cash why'd
you let her go
my choice I would have but I had it
after eight months I had to tell her to
leave
I said I'm not asking I'm telling you
you gotta leave
and
I've
why'd you tell her to leave
I knew she didn't buy into this she
didn't buy in to me not being the same
person and coming
into a relationship and
and I said I'm not sure I'm going to get
to back to normal again I wrote I'm
famous
because it's cool that I had a collision
with a celebrity
was that your thinking of the time and
you said yes do you deny it
I not if you have it on record no I
don't deny it I don't remember it may I
ask when this happened sure like one
hour ago two hours ago you told this
jury
I've never thought it was cool that I
had a collision with a celebrity do you
recall that
yeah yes I guess I did say that
absolutely and that's not a true
statement is it honestly I don't ever
remember saying it bring it up again I
don't just I don't doubt you I misspeak
a lot
Terry uh Sanderson said that Carlene
didn't buy into him being a different
person what do you think he meant by
that actually Jesse I think that was a
slip of the tongue he said buy into as
though he's trying to fake it and trying
to be a different person if he had
really meant look she can't accept me
because now I have all these injuries
and I'm not the same person he would
have said it that way but he said buy
into and the way I read that is he's
putting up this whole scam here that he
is now a different person some other
people have bought into it his daughters
have bought into it other people might
believe him his friends one who
testified for him but Carlene didn't buy
into it so he had to tell her to leave
and I think that's important I don't
know if the jury picked up on that I
think Owen the attorney for Paltrow
picked up on it and he asked about it in
the cross I thought that was a very good
point to make Brian never good to say I
misspeak on cross-examination I'm going
to ask you the same question I asked
about Paltrow you think he's credible so
it's a little bit different for me here
because I think that Owens pouches
attorneys held sanderson's feet to the
fire a little bit closer coming out I'm
with inconsistencies from prior
depositions and again he really wants to
talk and in that talking he kind of let
things slip Terry pointed out one that
was there but also when he talked about
um well I didn't write that that's
another one of my personalities my first
thing came up in mind was well which
personality is testifying now and there
was a lot of times where he's speaking
oh when I got hit it felt like I went
flying well didn't someone else testify
on his behalf that he couldn't have left
his feet that it wasn't possible so the
inconsistencies that I saw from him
mainly because he spoke a little bit too
much and also the attorneys for Paltrow
really pushed him on some of those
inconsistencies and now I'm thinking
maybe he's in it for the money and and
not because he actually got hurt here's
another way of looking at it maybe he
really believes that happened but his
memory is so altered by by the Collision
itself I mean that's another way of
looking at the end of the day the jury
is going to have to determine the
credibility of both Paltrow and
Sanderson but that's not all because
when we come back GoPro footage Paltrow
and Sanderson skiing Collision could
pretty much Clear things up once and for
all right but is there actually video
we're exploring key testimony from the
plaintiff's daughter next
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody so we're
continuing to talk about all things
Gwyneth Paltrow as she fights a lawsuit
followed by retired optometrist Terry
Sanderson and continues or counterswes
him herself now one standout witness
from last week was the plaintiff's
daughter Shea Sanderson Harris now she
broke down in tears during her testimony
as she described her father's condition
before and after the skiing Collision
Collision Harris even said that
sanderson's relationship with his
granddaughter was strained due to the
experience but one key piece of evidence
brought in during her testimony was an
email discussing a possible GoPro video
of the Collision a video that the court
hasn't seen yet let's hear what she had
to say about that video on the stand
uh will you go ahead and read what this
what your note says here for the jury
dad
I cannot believe how unlucky and how
crazy
all is
I also can't believe this is all on
GoPro what are the chances
I am so glad you're okay how are you
feeling this evening love Shay you you
mentioned you had a phone call yes yes
uh how did that instruct or have
influence on this response okay
um after my dad told me about what he
was feeling and that he could hardly
think he said there has to be GoPro
footage there just has to be because
there was this
big
um
blood curdling scream before I got hit
in the back and that means that a person
that had a helmet cam of this GoPro
would look towards the screen and catch
it all on video
and um so I thought that's brilliant you
know then we haven't we have
complete evidence of what happened and
who was at fault
but you had never he didn't show you a
GoPro video no I I've never seen GoPro
video and it does not exist as far as I
know
so Terry if I'm understanding this right
Sanderson refused help from the ski
patrol but then shortly after the
accident he discusses who's at fault
with his daughter what do you make of
that I think it's very interesting and
especially their discussion about the
GoPro video look it could very well be
that he wasn't hurt at all and that he
caused the accident himself and that he
thought maybe there was video out there
but they had a discussion about it
there's something very strange about the
phone call they had and then the email
text afterwards so I'm thinking and
maybe someone on the jury is thinking
that they're making up this after the
accident that he said he's okay he's
really all right but then they figure
out it's Gwyneth Paltrow maybe there's
some money there I mean it could be a
cynical viewpoint but they're just so
many inconsistencies and this GoPro is
also an inconsistency Brian was talking
about that earlier and I'm a little bit
confused why are you even talking about
this so I think someone on that jury
could think that he's making this all up
well Brian if you believe the
sanderson's that there's no GoPro you
think the email and the explanation is
going to hurt Terry's case yeah that's a
big if Jesse and I do I do things Gonna
Hurt let me explain this way over the
hundreds of cases that I've done in New
York City when someone's accused of of a
homicide a rape an assault whatever it
is and we think hey there's a bodega at
the corner there might be video there
there's a night show building here there
might be video at no point in time does
anyone affirmatively say there is a
video when we are thinking and trying to
explore if there is that is not how the
English language works and her
explanation of that was garbage in the
best of ways I think that is a daughter
doing exactly as she should be doing
protecting her father that made zero
sense to me and I think that's going to
hurt them in front of the jury she
should be telling the truth let's talk
about that Terry Brian thank you both so
much everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long Prime daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
thank you
foreign
[Music]